a clear-cut that's what Paul tell yard
made a few years back the Cape Town
native used to live on the streets
today he runs a carpentry workshop for
unemployed men and former criminals he
used to be the Menace and the poisonous
element now we the savers we come we
build we create jobs look after the kids
Paul started his social enterprise in
2010 in his late mother's house he
clearly remembers the day he decided to
make a change I suspect in the bins for
bottles that I could change and as I put
pan in the bin I put my onion in a pile
of dog poo and that was when I reached
rock bottom and I thought that's it I
said to the lady who runs this which
didn't listen are varied enough just to
help me change my life the woman at the
soup kitchen encouraged him to do
something for the men who would go there
and so he did
currently Paul employs twelve men at his
carpentry workshop sessile Salomon is
one of them which I regret it afterwards
but now and how I see the future is
bright and brilliant for me and I'm
really looking forward to keeping with
the heads of honour for a couple of more
years upcycling is the main principle of
Paul's venture he keeps the raw
materials in his backyard old furniture
and wood donated by companies and
individuals it's a win-win undertaking
Paul's business house reduced landfill
and also helps reduce crime we find that
unemployment is the root cause so the
main focus is on creating jobs so the
men can earn their own money and not
resort to stealing or welfare dependence
Paul doesn't believe in charity by
selling the furniture the men make
everything from benches crushed fittings
and crosses he's able to pay them a
monthly salary of three thousand Rand
Paul invests 50% of the income in
upgrading derelict buildings in his
community on the Cape Flats like this
former drug den now a clothing factory
over the last few years his team has
renovated 15 buildings in the area today
Paul and his men are attending to number
16 the local Scouts Hall is in desperate
need of renovations Paul has trained
around 50 men so far some of them do
revert back to crime he says but overall
the positive impact is evident in 2011
the police recognized Paul for helping
to reduce criminal activity in the area
after a few hours the scouts Hall looks
like new
Paul is proud it was a lot of work the
building was a bit of a sight for sore
eyes but thanks to the men
it looks great together project number
16 is finished and ready to be used by
the scouts team Paul's next goal a big
upcycling Center to fix up more
buildings and to create more jobs